herzlich willkommen in der
bundespressekonferenz herzlich
willkommen unseren gästen
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn und
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer es
geht um die wohnanlage und um die
einreise verordnungen und minister
sparen hat das wort liebe frau wefers
minister lieber horst meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren mit dem start
in die sommerferien fragen sich viele
bürgerinnen und bürger was gilt nun
und wie können wir einen sicheren urlaub
gestalten grund dafür ist nicht zuletzt
die delta variante die sich nach und
nach in ganz europa ausbreitet und delta
ist das sehen wir ansteckender als die
bisher bekannten varianten und sie hat
auch in ländern mit einer sehr hohen
anzahl von erstimpfungen wie dem
vereinigten königreich zu einem
signifikanten anstieg der infektionen
geführt
delta wird auch bald in deutschland die
dominierende variante sein
ich gehe davon aus dass wir noch im juli
sehen werden das gelte auch bei uns über
70 80 prozent der infektionen ausmacht
die erfolgen
entscheidend ist unter welchen
bedingungen das passiert das ziel dabei
ist für uns klar es geht darum die
absoluten infektionszahlen möglichst
niedrig zu halten und gleichzeitig das
impf tempo weiter zu erhöhen wenn das
eine ist ja der relative anteil den die
delta variante ausmacht eine
infektionszahlen die mindestens genauso
entscheidende frage ist ja die der
absoluten zahlen an neuinfektionen und
die sind weiterhin sehr sehr niedrig mit
einer 7 tages incidents deutlich unter
10 für das ganze bundesgebiet die zahl
der neuinfektionen sinkt auch weiter und
gleichzeitig halten wir das impf tempo
hoch stand heute nachdem es gestern
wieder fast eine million impfung gegeben
hat haben wir über 75 millionen
impfungen in deutschland geben können
über 55 prozent der bevölkerung hat
bereits eine erste impfung bekommen dass
in fast 46 millionen bürgerinnen und
bürger das sind übrigens 23
aller erwachsenen in deutschland die
mindestens einmal geimpft sind zwei von
drei erwachsenen in deutschland sind
mindestens einmal game das reicht noch
nicht aber das ist schon mal eine gute
zwischen etappe über 37% genaugenommen
37,3 prozent haben bereits die zweite
impfung das sind über 31 millionen
bürgerinnen und bürger übrigens von den
zwölf- bis 18-jährigen sind etwa 7%
bisher mindestens einmal geimpft das
sind gut 400.000 kinder und jugendliche
und auch hier gilt das was wir in den
letzten wochen immer gesagt haben auch
für die zwölf- bis 18-jährigen werden
wir bis ende august bei denjenigen wie
wollen die das für sich entscheiden es
möglich machen dass sie mindestens die
erste impfung erhalten haben können
es sind kann ich übrigens nur sehr
werden auch für strukturierte angebote
gerade auch für die jüngeren erwachsenen
an den universitäten oder an den
berufsschulen wir sehen gerade wir haben
gestern die usa überholt wenn sie so
wollen bei den erst impfungen die ja
sehr stark auch gestartet waren
das zeigt erstens welches tempo wie
mittlerweile auch in deutschland beim
impfen haben aber es zeigt ihm auch wie
wichtig ist es bei der impfkampagne den
langen atem den langen atem zu haben und
vor allem jetzt auch die
impfbereitschaft weiter zu erhöhen bzw
die bereitschaft zu tatsächlichen
impfungen zu führen und deswegen sind
angebote gerade für auch die jungen
erwachsenen wie gesagt der trank
universitäten und berufsschulen sehr
sehr wichtig das heißt eben auch wir
werden unser versprechen dass wir jeden
in deutschland bis zum ende des sommers
ein impfangebot und das heißt eine erste
impfung werden geben können halten und
das deutlich früher als geplant das
hilft uns jetzt denn früher als
angenommen mehr erstimpfungen das heißt
auch dass insgesamt mehr bürgerinnen und
bürger früher vollständig geschützt
werden sein können nach der zweiten
impfung und erst der komplette schutz
hilft gut gegen delta doppelt geimpft
schützt gegen delta niedrige incidents
geringe infektionszahlen durch hohe
impfquoten diese erfolge gilt es jetzt
zu sichern und da sind wir beim thema
urlaub und einreise bzw
rückreise aus risikogebieten um einen
starken eintrag aus anderen ländern zu
minimieren haben wir seitens der
bundesregierung auch in guter abstimmung
zwischen innen und
gesundheitsministerium erarbeitet eine
einreise verordnung für deutschland die
vergleichsweise strikt ist die möchten
wir heute am ersten juni zu beginn der
sommerzeit und für viele eben damit auch
der reisezeit noch einmal in erinnerung
rufen alle länder in denen das corona
virus so zirkuliert dass es uns besorgt
werden in drei kategorien unterteilt
einfache risikogebiete hoch incidents
gebiete und virusvarianten gebiete vom
verfahren her ist es übrigens so dass
jede woche auswärtiges amt
innenministerium und
gesundheitsministerium sich mehrfach
zusammen setzen alle länder und ihrer
entwicklung bezüglich der
infektionszahlen miteinander sich
anschauen da wo es keine guten zahlen
gibt aus den behörden offiziell vor ort
tipps zum beispiel auch berichte der
botschaften die mit einfließen so dass
dann immer zum ende jeder woche die drei
ministerien gemeinsam und einvernehmlich
die kategorisierung vornehmen und das
robert-koch-institut sie dann
veröffentlicht wichtig ist hoch
incidents gebiet heißt eine mehrfache
incidents dessen was wir in deutschland
haben also ein hohes infektionsgeschehen
es wird individuell bewertet aber
spätestens bei über 200 neuinfektionen
in den letzten sieben tagen gilt ein
land als hoch incidents gebet
virusvarianten gebiet das sind länder wo
virusvarianten auch neue virusvarianten
insbesondere mit einem möglicherweise
oder wahrscheinlich besonderem risiko
wie vero nancy variance of concern
virusvarianten mit wahrscheinlich
besonderem risiko auftreten und
gleichzeitig diese variante bei uns in
deutschland nicht verbreitet auftritt es
kann noch mal deutlich machen am
beispiel der so genannten britischen
variante jetzt den alfa die war zu
beginn in deutschland auf sehr niedrigen
niveau in den infektionszahlen
dann in tschechien und tirol einen sehr
hohen quoten da haben wir diese beiden
länder bzw
regionen wie virus zu virusvarianten
gebieten erklärt mit sehr klaren regeln
und als wir dann eben gesehen haben dass
die britische mutter spyker muss ich
jetzt immer sagen alpha auch bei uns
dominieren wird haben wir diese länder
zu hoch incidents gebieten und dann mit
infektionsgeschehen dann auch weiter
unterstufen können
und das gilt jetzt auch mit blick auf
delta wenn wir sehen dass diese variante
in deutschland an relativen anteil
gewinnt dominieren wird
um gleichzeitig wir mittlerweile und das
ist schon ein unterschied zu dem wissen
von vor gut einer woche wissen dass die
impfung auch bei delta schützen
zumindest die doppelte impfung der volle
impfschutz
dann werden wir uns jetzt eben in den
nächsten tagen die situation nochmal
anschauen und wenn sich dass beide so
bestätigt wird man portugal und das
vereinigte königreich dann auch wie ein
hoch incidents gebiet behandeln können
ich sage dass deswegen weil es eine
große diskussion gerade gibt über
geimpfte aus virusvarianten gebeten
jetzt mit dem wissen dass sich in den
letzten tagen bestätigt hat dass bei
dieser variante die doppelte impfung
schützt haben wir ihm auch die
möglichkeit dann zu einer anderen
einstufung zu kommen so dass auch hier
die doppelte impfung ein unterschied
macht aber wir arbeiten eben nach dem
vorsichtsprinzip erst wenn wir wissen
dass das für eine neue variante gilt
etwa bezogen auf den impfstoff kommen
wir dann zu entsprechenden entscheidung
generell gilt jeder der sich in einen
flieger nach deutschland setzt und zwar
egal wie das jeweilige land aus dem
abgeflogen wird kategorisiert ist muss
ein negatives testergebnis oder ein
gültigen im oder genesenen nachweis vor
betreten des flugzeuges vorlegen du
willst ein ganz entscheidender
unterschied im vergleich zum letzten
jahr
diese regelung gilt für jeden flug nach
deutschland vor abflug ist dem
beförderer vorzulegen oder genesenen
nachweis oder ein aktuelles negatives
testergebnis wir aus einfachen
risikogebieten aus hoch incidents
gebieten oder virusvarianten gebieten
kommt muss
eine digitale einreise anmeldung
ausfüllen übrigens auch anders als
letztes jahr da haben wir noch über
papier aussteige karten geredet und die
frage wie wir dieses papier dann auch
schnell zu den gesunden zu den
gesundheitsämtern vor ort bringen
das geht jetzt digital und damit können
die gesundheitsämter auch sehen
tagesaktuell wer sich in ihrem
zuständigkeitsbereich aus ein
risikogebiet eingereist aufhält wer aus
einem hoch incidents gebiet oder einem
virus varianten gebiet einreist muss bei
der einreise ein test im vorgelesenen
nachweis mit sich führen das gilt eben
nicht nur bei flug sondern generell bei
der einreise aus hoch incidents oder
virusvarianten gebieten auch auf anderen
beförderungs wegen ist ein
entsprechender nachweis mit sich zu
führen wer aus einem einfachen
risikogebiet einreist muss einen solchen
nachweis in deutschland dann etwa durch
eine testung in deutschland binnen 48
stunden dann auch machen quarantäne
pflichten auch das ist wichtig
quarantäne pflichten gibt es für
rückreisende aus allen drei kategorien
wer aus einem risikogebiet aus einem
hoch incidents gebiet oder einem virus
varianten gebiet einreist muss
grundsätzlich mindestens zehn tage in
quarantäne
diese quarantäne kann nur durch aktives
vorlegen eines negativen testergebnisses
gegenüber dem zuständigen gesundheitsamt
kann auch digital erfolgen verkürzt
werden und zwar beim risikogebiet mit
der vorlage des negativen
testergebnisses oder das impf nachweises
beim hoch incidents gebiet frühestens
nach fünf tagen also bei hoch incidents
gilt mindestens fünf tage quarantäne
dann kann man sich durch einen test
nachweis entsprechend die quarantäne
verkürzen und sonst zehn tage beim
virusvarianten gerät ist gar keine
verkürzung der dann 14-tägigen
quarantäne möglich was übrigens auch
wichtig ist aus virusvarianten gebieten
dürfen beförderer nur deutsche und
menschen bürgerinnen und bürger mit
einem wohnsitz in deutschland nach
deutsch
lang befördern auch das zeigt wie ernst
wir das thema virusvarianten gebiete
nehmen und wie klar die regeln dort sind
generell bitten wir jede bürgerin jeden
bürger in deutschland auch jetzt über
den sommer
lassen sie sich bitte impfen oder lassen
sie sich bitte regelmäßig testen und
idealerweise das kostenlose angebot ist
da als bürger test ein bis zweimal die
woche wer nicht geimpft ist und vor
allem auch kontakt mit anderen hat bitte
regelmäßig testen entweder bürger test
oder auch dem selbsttest der
mittlerweile sehr breit und auch
vergleichsweise günstig verfügbar ist
das ist ein weiterer wichtiger
unterschied im vergleich zum letzten
jahr
wir haben tests on mars verfügbar
letztes jahr hatten wir nur pcr-test
kapazitäten und die waren relativ knapp
wir haben hier in diesem jahr deutlich
mehr möglichkeiten und diese generelle
empfehlung sich regelmäßig testen zu
lassen wenn man nicht geimpft ist
die gilt natürlich auch für
reiserückkehrer die frage wie es wird
nach ende des sommers und der
urlaubsreise zeit haben wir ja selbst in
der hand und die frage wie es in der
schule wird zum beispiel wenn sich alle
die zurückkehren oder wiedereinreise
nach deutschland nach der einreise auch
freiwillig im abstand von zwei drei
tagen wieder selbst testen oder testen
lassen beim kostenlosen bürger test dann
macht er schon einen großen unterschied
ist kann man übrigens auch machen wenn
man nicht aus risikogebieten kommt und
wer also sicher starten will für sich
und für andere in der schule am
arbeitsplatz im alltag der hat die
möglichkeit und dazu können wir nur
auffordern und ermuntern sich auch in
den regelmäßigen abstand testen zu
lassen und für sich und für andere
sicherheit zu geben und dann gibt es
einen letzten wichtigen aspekt und da
bin ich sehr dankbar für die
zusammenarbeit auch zwischen bund und
ländern da geht es um die kontrolle bei
der einreise und um die kontrolle der
quarantäne an der gesundheitsämter vor
ort wissen können wissen durch die
digitale ein reiseanmeldung während
ihrem zuständigkeitsbereich einer
quarantäne pflicht unterliegt und jetzt
ist eben sehr wichtig dass diese auch
stichproben
hatte ich jedenfalls kontrolliert wird
die freien kapazitäten dieses wegen
geringerer infektionszahlen gibt denke
ich machen dass auch möglich also
zusammengefasst
wir haben deutlich mehr möglichkeiten
als vor einem jahr
wir haben vor beginn der reisezeit klare
regeln
das war letztes jahr die wir uns
erinnern anders wir haben ein breites
testangebot und breite testmöglichkeiten
wir haben sehr viel informieren können
und werden auch weiter informieren und
wir haben bessere möglichkeiten zur
kontrolle etwa durch die digitale
einreise anmeldung und werden übrigens
noch etwas wir haben die impfung die
natürlich den ganz entscheidenden
unterschied machen und so haben wir es
selbst in der hand ob dann aus einem
schönen urlaub auf eine schöne folgezeit
hinein in den herbst folgt oder nicht es
liegt am ende an uns ob delta in
deutschland eine chance in
anführungszeichen hat ein risiko für uns
wird oder nicht
kinder kein minister spanz wurden mir
schon zahlreiche fragen vor aber herr
seehofer hat jetzt erst mal das wort
vorsitzende jens meine damen und herren
diese koroma virus einreise verordnung
ist ein stimmiges ausgewogenes system
und regeln wenn es vielleicht als
kompliziert erscheint dann will ich noch
mal darauf hinweisen dass wir gezwungen
sind differenzierte lösungen zu treffen
denn die
gerichte schauen sehr darauf dass wir
bei unserem tun grundsätze wie zum
beispiel die verhältnismäßigkeit
berücksichtigen und wir würden sofort
vor gericht scheitern wenn wir
unabhängig vom riesigen und ähnlichem
festlegungen treffen würden das zwingt
also auch zu sehr differenzierten
lösungen
ich konzentriere mich auf die kontrolle
denn entscheidend ist dass die maßnahmen
aus der einreise verordnung auch
durchgesetzt werden
vor allem auch die qualität pflichten
die ja in jedem fall gegeben sind
für die quarantäne pflichten haben wir
ja letztes jahr ein neues system
entwickelt eine digitale ein
reiseanmeldung die von jeder person
gemacht werden muss diese digitale
einreise an meldungen kommt als
information wenn die gesundheitsämter
ihre schubladen aufmachen an die
gesundheit sein kann die
gesundheitsämter müssen die einhaltung
der quarantäne pflicht überwachen
mit den frei testens möglichkeiten die
die entspannen geschildert hat wenn ich
also beinahe täglich von irgendeinem
ministerpräsidenten aufgefordert werden
die grenzen stärker zu kontrollieren
dann kann ich nur sagen scheiden die
kontrollmöglichkeit ist die kontrolle
durch die gesundheitsämter
daneben ist die bundespolizei für die
überwachung der einreise zuständig zwar
alleine zuständig und da möchte ich also
erst die botschaft vermitteln dass es
nicht beabsichtigt ist
an den außengrenzen der bundesrepublik
deutschland statt zu der grenzkontrollen
einzuführen
wir haben an der grenze zu österreich
eine grenzkontrolle
aus migrations und terror gründen aber
aus pandemie gründen werden wir
nirgendwo in deutschland eine stationäre
grenzkontrollen einführen
die zwei fragen die hier wichtig sind
was wird kontrolliert und wie dicht
kontrollieren wer wo die bundespolizei
kontrolliert dass die digitale ein
reiseanmeldung dass die erstattet worden
ist denn die ist voraussetzung dass die
gesundheitsämter die information haben
dass jemand eingereist ist sie
kontrolliert die nachweise für die
testungen und auch die nachweise für
genießer kommen und impfungen
je nach herkunftsland natürlich da wird
das entscheidende
auf den flughäfen stattfinden und dort
gibt es heute schon eine lückenlose
kontrolle also jedes flugpassagiere
unabhängig davon war sehr entspannend
gesagt hat dass man schon beim boarden
diese nachweise zu erbringen hat
kontrolliert zum beispiel bei fluglinien
aus russland variation virusvarianten
gebiet das die voraussetzungen die wir
rechtlich vorschreiben erfüllt sind
im übrigen werden wir bei diesen flügen
aus nicht farias varianten gebieten die
kontrolle
die kontrolldichte weiter erhöhen auf
den flughäfen so dass ich glaube wir
sehr dafür sorgen werden dass auch die
regeln der einreise verordnung von der
bevölkerung beachtet werden
auf dem landweg ich sagte es gibt keine
stationären grenzkontrollen geben wir
werden aber hinter der grenze den
sogenannten die sogenannte
schleierfahndung in bezug auf die
pandemie fertigten verstärken
und da muss man nach derzeitigem stand
das kann sich jede woche ändern
darauf hinweisen dass wir im moment eher
von keinem risiko gebiet umgeben sind
von der in der bundesrepublik
deutschland so dass jetzt die
schleierfahndung hinter der grenze also
für die für den autoverkehr sich vor
allem nach derzeitigem stand darauf
richten wird wer auf der balkanroute aus
der türkei zurück kommt oder den die
autorin für den weg aus großbritannien
in die politik deutschland wählt wir
gehen aber nicht davon aus dass es ein
besonders hohes aufkommen sein wird so
dass trotzdem wusste es auch
kontrolliert werden weil auch dort
müssen ja die leute damit rechnen dass
sie kontrolliert werden
aber das ist mit der schleierfahndung
etwas völlig anderes als mit der
stationären grenzkontrollen die
gewaltige rückstaus auch zur folge hat
zusammengefasst möchte ich für den punkt
der kontrolle sagen
das ist die botschaft klar ist wer
einreist muss damit rechnen kontrolliert
zu werden wir werden also sehr darauf
achten dass die regeln in der praxis
auch beachtet werden und das müssen wir
um ein zusätzliches einschleusen von
infektionsgeschehen in die
bundesrepublik deutschland zu vermeiden
und damit den erfolg zu sichern den wir
bisher in deutschland diesbezüglich
haben
herr minister seehofer also ich habe
jetzt schon am anfang
ich habe schon ein gutes dutzend fragen
vorliegen mein ziel wäre es dass wir
damit durchkommen und wahrscheinlich
kommt ja auch die eine oder andere noch
dazu die erste hat haring frage geht
wahrscheinlich eher an ein spaß an einem
seehofer wenn sie dazu auch das sagen
wollen und zwar geht es um die die virus
varianten gebiet einstufung sie haben
darauf hingewiesen dass das delta
virusvariante sich auch im juli auf 70
80 prozent in deutschland ausbreiten
kann ab wann genau ab welcher schwelle
können denn länder wie großbritannien
oder portugal damit rechnen dass sie
heruntergestuft werden dass
interessierte frage der vergleichsgröße
also sozusagen wenn die quote der
relative anteil
ein vergleichbarer ist dann wird das der
fall sein wenn ich 70 80 prozent sagen
und das ist in diesen beiden ländern
vergleichsweise gleiche größenordnung
dann kann man eine entsprechende
herunterstufung vornehmen und das zweite
wichtige kriterium ist ja die frage ist
das eine variante die insbesondere was
ihre eigenschaften angeht was den
impfschutz angeht aber auch die frage
von ansteckungsfähigkeit infektiosität
und welche krankheitsbilder können
daraus folgen ein unterschied macht der
für uns problematisch wäre im vergleich
zu der variante die wir uns
vorherrschend ist und gerade dieses
thema
dass die impfung jedenfalls der volle
wurde doppelte impfung oder bei johnson
johnson die einfache der volle
impfschutz bei delta hilft ist auch für
die einordnung als virusvarianten gebiet
noch ein wichtiges kriterium und mit
diesen beiden kriterien und der
entwicklung die ich in deutschland sehe
gehe ich davon aus dass wir bei unserer
regelmäßigen überarbeitung dort dann
auch ja nicht gar nichts mehr gelten
lassen also ich sage nochmal residenz
gebiet heißt fünf tage quarantäne heißt
auch testen heißt auch im nachweis
entsprechend zu erbringen
aber es zeigt eben andersherum auch dass
wir dieses schärfste instrument und
virusvarianten gebiet des echten
scharfes instrument bis hin zum
beförderungsverbot für nichtdeutsche
dass wir das eben auch mit bedacht aber
auch als vorsichtsmaßnahme einsetzt da
habe ich noch mal kurz nachfragen und
zeitlich präziser zu machen das heißt
dass diese woche schon einstufung von
portugal und großbritannien kommen
könnte es zeitlich nicht verwirrend zu
machen würde ich sagen lassen wir jetzt
erstmal auswärtiges amt innenministerium
und gesundheitsministerium gemeinsam die
bewertung vornehmen
ich will jetzt einfach nicht weil das
löst ja was aus bei allen beteiligten
und dem reiseverkehr jetzt nicht auf
einen tag mich hier festlegen ich habe
ihn nur die kriterien genannt und dass
wir das jetzt eben wie alles beständig
weiter überprüfen werden
es wird jedenfalls nicht entferner ferne
liegen das ist offenkundig angesichts
der entwicklung der junge das wort
anfrage an den sportminister aber auch
an den gesundheitsminister zum zur
fußball-wm die uefa hat jetzt beim spiel
deutschland gegen england 45.000
menschen ins wembley stadion gelassen in
einem land wo delta grassiert im final
beim finale sollen 60.000 menschen im
stadion
halten sie diese entscheidung der uefa
in irgendeiner weise für vertretbar und
nachvollziehbar und halt und sind sie
auch der meinung wie herr lauterbach
dass die uefa für den tod von vielen
menschen verantwortlich sein wird ich
halte diese
position der uefa für absolut
verantwortungslos der kuli warum weil
wir in der zeit einer pandemie leben und
gerade in solchen ländern wie
großbritannien ja das geschehen sehr
stark ist und wir alle wissen dass es
das muss man über den erinnerungen
wurden natürlich die kontakt vermeidung
und bestimmte jene vorschriften
unabdingbar sind um die infektion eines
tages zu überwinden
und wenn sie die bilder anschauen wenn
die menschen sehr dicht aufeinander sind
dann noch die folge feiern mit kursen
umarmungen und all diese dinge ist
vorgezeichnet dass dies auch das
infektionsgeschehen befördert ich war
selbst bei dem eröffnungsspiel in
münchen und hatte dass die gewissheit
weil ich gesehen habe dass sowohl im
vorbereich all diejenigen maßnahmen
berücksichtigt waren als dann auch in
[Musik]
der arena selbst da sind die leute dann
wenn das hat ein fassungsvermögen von
80.000 zuschauern und wenn dann 14.000
drin sind ist es auch eine unterstützung
für die mannschaften aber unter jene
gesichtspunkten sind die leute auch die
sogenannten peps weit auseinander
gesessen und ich habe mich gefreut wenn
du das die stadt ist wie gesagt für mich
ist halb münchen
das hat funktioniert und wie es auch
nichts bekannt geworden dass außer
hingegen dann ein problem entstanden ist
gestern habe ich habe gelesen dass
irgendwo auf der britischen insel
durchaus infektionen stattgefunden haben
also
ich weiß es nicht einfach kontrolliert
es macht schon sinn
das war ja als sport ministerium unserer
ganzes bestreben auch in der
fußball-bundesliga in der zweiten liga
in der dritten liga dass wir uns mit den
gesundheitsbehörden auf rettung
verständigen die mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit gewährleisten dass
solche events nicht zu einem ausbreiten
desinfektions geschehens führen kann man
überhaupt nicht erklären warum die usa
hier nicht in der linie der vernunft
folgt der kollege tom kummer von
t-online es mich an fragt sie herrn
spahn ob es überhaupt noch
verantwortlich ist zwar em spiele in
london abzuhalten und verweist auf die
infektion der schottischen fans genau
die habe ich gelesen ich habe schon 2003
infizierter sicht hat der bundesminister
ad horst seehofer dazu gerade alles
notwendige gesagt wunderbare kollegin
hat das wort
hinter dem rinke die gerade auf ihrem
telefon tipp diesen die linke habe will
ich das nie vergessen darf ich habe da
ein bisschen den verdacht dass es da
wieder um kommerz geht und kommerz darf
nicht den infektionsschutz für die
bevölkerung überstrahlen
ich erinnere mich dass vor beginn der
europameisterschaft die uefa münchen
aufgefordert hat zuschauer zuzulassen
sonst würden sie nicht mehr als standort
oder spielort in frage kommen
und ich habe das damals schon für sehr
sehr unverantwortlich gehalten das
konnte in münchen nur eine frage sein
mit dem gesundheitsamt kann man was
verantworten und das muss die regel sein
kollege das haben wir beachtet in
deutschland und werden es auch weiterhin
beachten
und das gilt für alle sportereignisse ob
sie die eishockey-meisterschaft gesehen
haben oder handball oder basketball
wir haben ganz strikte regeln und mir
ist kein event bekannt jens wo
außenveranstaltungen sozusagen eine
verbreitung der infektion erfolgt
einzelne spieler haben sich mal
infiziert sind aber in quarantäne
geschickt worden
aber eine eine massenhafte erscheinung
ist daraus nicht erfolgt und das heißt
wir sind bisher sehr sehr
verantwortungsvoll damit umgegangen und
ich kann nur an die uefa wieder
appellieren sie soll das nicht
abschieben auf wieder die örtlichen
gesundheitsbehörden sondern ein
sportverband sollte schon klar erklären
wir wollen das nicht so wir reduzieren
die zuschauerzahl frau kollegin sie
haben das wort spiekermann zdf aber ich
habe jetzt ein kleines gebiet ich wollte
noch mal bei den schulen nachfragen ja
es geht hier jetzt das lässt sich ja
nicht ordnen machen sie da weiter ich
habe hier zahlreiche themen ich wollte
noch mal fragen den schulen sparen weil
sie jetzt auch selbst angesprochen haben
es gibt es diese zahl dass nur zehn
prozent der schulen überhaupt einen
luftfilter haben wie sehen sie die
situation wenn die ferien zu ende sind
wenn der stand jetzt schon so schlecht
ist und ist ja auch studien dazu gibt es
filter in schulen in klassenräumen
durchaus hilfreich sein kann wenn mir
gestern im bundeskabinett
auch ein bericht des
gesundheitsministeriums ist familien
jugendministeriums beraten wo es um die
situation von kindern und jugendlichen
in der pandemie in den letzten 18
monaten geht und was wir sehen ist die
sehr große psychische belastung die es
gerade bei vielen kindern und
jugendlichen gibt man muss hier nur
vergegenwärtigen ein sechsjähriges kind
hat jetzt eineinhalb jahre seines lebens
in dieser pandemie verbracht wir haben 2
32 drittklässler die haben noch nie
richtigen schulunterricht erlebt durch
die situation wie sie ist
wir sehen das im übrigen auch durchaus
bezogen auf die körperliche gesundheit
was mobilität angeht was internetnutzung
mediennutzung angeht und damit eben
weniger körperliche aktivität also ein
ganz ganz vielen aspekten bis hin
natürlich auch zu familiären schwierigen
situationen und all das führt zu einem
was wir im übrigen ich erinnere mich
noch sehr gut dass sich das im märz 2020
hier an dieser stelle oder besser an der
stelle weil jetzt als die frau
bundeskanzlerin sitzen gesagt habe
nämlich das ist eine wichtige priorität
ist schulen und kitas so lange als
möglich jedenfalls offen zu halten und
auch in einem normalen betrieb zu haben
das gilt für mich auch nach dem sommer
sehr sehr klar
voraussetzung dafür sind aber eben wie
sie schon sagen die notwendigen konzepte
und jetzt haben ja die schulministerin
und minister der länder zu recht letzte
woche noch mal den bund darauf
hingewiesen dass die zuständigkeit bei
den ländern ist das akzeptiere ich
absolut aber ist es eben wichtig das was
dann auch passiert in dem sinne wir
haben ja die werkzeuge regelmäßiges
testen die testangebote gerade in den
schulen ist es wichtig zwei mal die
woche
die testangebote zu machen das thema
lüften ob es durch lüften des raumes ist
ob es jedenfalls zu beginn nach dem
sommer aufgrund der temperaturen dann
eben auch möglicherweise im freien ist
oder daneben richtung herbst winter
durch entsprechende lüftungsanlagen die
frage der impfung im übrigen für die
jedenfalls mal universitäten in dem
jetzt mal im bereich jugend etwas weiter
als nur die bis zu 18-jährigen wir haben
die berufsschulen
wir haben die universitäten wo übrigens
auch viel präsenzveranstaltungen
ausgefallen sind fast keine
stattgefunden haben wir haben auch
erstsemester zwei semester die haben
noch nie die uni zum jedenfalls zur zur
vorlesung von innen gesehen
dort kann man eben auch mit impfen einen
unterschied machen wie auch mit dem
impfen der erzieherinnen und erzieher
der lehrerinnen und lehrer sie werkzeuge
sind da und ich finde die kinder und
jugendliche haben es nach all den härten
der letzten 100 jahre verdient dass das
die oberste priorität aller
verantwortlichen ist dass schulen so
normal als möglich
kitas starten können nach dem sommer ein
zusatz also sie sagen die länder müssen
jetzt mal land gewinnen und ich habe
alles gerade dazu gesagt ich würde an
sie beide einmal herzlich appellieren
wir haben ungefähr 50 prozent der zeit
um und wir haben ungefähr fünf prozent
der fragen beantwortet das ist ein
gewisses missverhältnis vielleicht
können wir das ein bisschen
beschleunigen herr gabriel ist vom
deutschlandfunk stellt auch auf die
schulen ab und repariert den präsidenten
des deutschen lehrerverbandes herrn
meidinger der kritisiert hat dass der
gesundheitsschutz fehlt unter anderem
raum luftfilter und fragt konkret wer
trägt die verantwortung dafür dass
schulen bei der pandemie bekämpfung
vergessen werden sie herrn sparen also
dass das thema schule und
schulunterricht nicht im blick wäre also
jede ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die
ich erlebt habe und das waren jetzt
nahezu alle der letzten eineinhalb jahre
hatte als eines der hauptthemen die
frage wie geht es den schulen geht das
weiter ist ja nicht so als wenn wir
nicht um diese frage stundenlang
miteinander gerungen haben weil es auch
einfach eine frage ist die millionen von
menschen kinder und jugendliche eltern
lehrerinnen lehrer erzählt er betrifft
in ihrem und für ihren alltag und
deswegen geht es da ja auch nicht um
wahrheiten sondern um das abwägen ganz
unterschiedliche aspekte und interessen
das was das eben zum beispiel für folgen
hat für kinder und jugendliche wenn die
schule nicht stattfindet aber natürlich
anders rum und das ist ja dann
abwägungsprozess der gesundheitsschutz
und der infektionsschutz der dann auch
mit dagegen zu gewichten ist sozusagen
in der abwehr im abwägungsprozess was
die lüftung angeht hat der bund
jedenfalls jetzt nochmal auch bestätigt
und ausgebaut ja ein förderprogramm
aufgelegt gibt finanzielle unterstützung
da wo es notwendig ist geben wir gerne
auch weitere unterstützung wo das
einbauen von filtern in schulräumen kann
jedenfalls nicht der bund anordnen oder
vornehmen das können nur schulträger und
diejenigen die sozusagen
dann auch in der organisation
verantwortlich sind wir unterstützen
nach besten wissen und gewissen und vor
allem auch finanziell aber das einbauen
in jeder einzelnen schule in deutschland
kann tatsächlich in zentralen
miteinander ich die bundesregierung
machen
vielen dank dann geht's weiter mit dem
essen eine frage die ich eigentlich
gerne herrn wieder gestellt hatte ja
angekündigt war können sie uns kurz
sagen warum gestern entschieden wurde
ihnen doch wieder auf dem podium zu
nehmen die inhaltliche frage ist sind
auch oder welche unter welchen
bedingungen würden diese lockerung die
sich ja bei den reisebedingungen
letztlich handelt kontrollierte
lockerung man müsste das wieder
rückgängig gemacht werden ist also ein
szenario denkbar wo sie sagen jetzt
steigen instanzen dorf wieder
entscheidung die bereiche dass ihr das
wieder enger fassen müssen wie sehr ein
solches szenario aus die terminfrage
kann ich vielleicht beantworten weil wir
hier die gastgeber sind es gibt es
schwierig 34 beschäftigte menschen unter
einen hut zu bringen und deshalb haben
wir uns gefragt dass jetzt die beiden
sind
bitte schön da wir eine rückfrage
stellen welche lockerungen meinen sie
dass das ein reisemanagement kommt mir
so vor als handle es sich um ein
sozusagen kontrollierte öffnungs
instrument um möglichst viel
reiseverkehr zu ermöglichen und generell
haben wir es mit einer politik so nehme
ich das war zunehmender lockerungen in
deutschland zu tun
in der eindruck falsch ist würde ich das
gerne
deswegen frage ich ja wurde erhält er
rührt das ist ja dann offenkundig ein
eher gefühlte eindruck weil ja die frage
ist zum beispiel im vergleich zu letztem
jahr urlaubszeit sommerzeit
machen wir doch mal andersrum was ist
anders wir haben rechtzeitig früh zu
übrigens mit beschluss von bund und
ländern ich würde mal sagen ich war
selbst in münchen dabei eine
gesundheitsministerkonferenz hybrid war
beim vorsitzender der
gesundheitskonferenz in münchen
zu dieser hybriden eintägigen tagung der
gesundheitsminister die haben bund und
länder gemeinsam dieses einreise konzept
noch einmal bestätigt dass die einreise
verordnung des bundes ist rechtzeitig
und frühzeitig vor dem reiseverkehr ein
ganz wichtiger unterschied zum letzten
die regeln sind klar ab dem ersten tag
der urlaubszeit
wir haben sehr strikte regeln und sie
sind auch nicht weniger strikt als
letztes jahr
was die frage angeht wir haben
ausdifferenzierte regel das stimmt
übrigens nicht zuletzt wegen der
bundesinnenminister hat darauf
hingewiesen wie ein gericht urteilen die
gesagt haben ihr müsst das schon jeweils
begründen und herleiten
ihr könnt nicht ein gebiet das ein
vergleichbares oder gar niedrigeres
infektionsgeschehen hat als deutschland
behandeln wie lorenz events gebiet also
ihr könnt nicht sozusagen als
gesetzgeber und verordnungsgeber
ungleiches gleich ist ungleich behandeln
so muss es formuliert und deswegen waren
wir in der pflicht und das haben wir
gemacht wie ich finde auch sehr
nachvollziehbar eben das aus zu
differenzieren und diese drei kategorien
aber die sind sehr sehr klar
letztes jahr gab es nicht die klare
regel für virusvarianten gebiete das
nicht deutsche und menschen die nicht
einen wohnsitz in deutschland haben
nicht befördert werden dürfen ich will
das noch mal in erinnerung rufen das ist
eine der schärfsten maßnahmen überhaupt
denkbar ist für diese gebiete quarantäne
regeln wir haben test verpflichtungen
vor jedem abflug nach deutschland
es gibt es erst seit märz es gab es
lässt es ja nicht nahm sogar gesetzlich
noch verankert entsprechend damit wieder
auch rechtssicher sind also wenn ich den
vergleich zählt zu den regelungen die
gegolten haben zu den regelungen die
jetzt gelten dann sind das sehr klare
sehr strikte regeln wenn es jetzt
konkrete vorschläge gibt einzelne
maßnahmen nochmals zu prüfen dann prüfen
wir die auch wir sind ja da überhaupt
nicht wenn dich nicht offen für gute
vorschläge was nur uns wichtig ist und
deswegen bin ich auch sehr dankbar dass
horst seehofer das gerät noch mal auch
so klar betont hat ist das eine sind die
regeln das andere ist die kontrolle
also es bringt ja nichts nach immer
neuen regeln zu rufen wenn die die da
sind die regeln nicht auch schon
vernünftig kontrolliert werden und bei
der quarantäne kontrolle jedenfalls ist
es sehr sehr wichtig dass die auch
erfolgt und dass die stadt findet wie
auch vor allem bei der einreise die
nicht über den flug
daneben auch da die stichprobenartige
kontrolle hier beschrieben
ich habe noch eine regel frage von
sozusagen von der kollegin birgit
schmeitzner vom ard hauptstadtstudio sie
fragt so quarantäne nach rückkehr warum
müssen reisende die aus virusvarianten
gebieten etwa portugal nach deutschland
kommen trotzdem in quarantäne selbst
wenn sie doppelt geimpft sind genesen
oder negativ getestet wie es aussieht
ist deutschland in wenigen tagen selbst
an varianten gebiet dann geht das ja
offenbar nicht mehr
können sie uns diese logik dahinter
erklären die logik ist das
vorsichtsprinzip dass wir zuerst einmal
wenn wir ein land zum virusvarianten
gebiet erklären ja noch nicht wissen was
diese variante wird dann ein very end of
konzern konzern wie es heißt bei der
aero also eine variante die besorgnis
erregt weil man über sie noch nicht
ausreichend viel weiß aber die vermutung
da ist das entweder was die entwicklung
angeht was die infektiosität angeht und
oder was mögliche krankheitsverläufe
angeht diese variante für uns
schwieriger ist als die die wir bisher
haben und vor allem diese frage ist der
impfschutz voll da oder nicht die können
wir beim auftreten einer neuen variante
nicht binnen tagen immer gleich
beantworten weil es dafür studien
braucht weil das untersucht werden muss
und als diese damals noch indische
variante jetzt delta erstmalig
aufgetreten ist war das absolut nicht
klar mittlerweile und das gerade gestern
ja noch neue studien veröffentlicht
worden
mittlerweile sehen wir dass der volle
impfschutz auch bei der delta variante
einen unterschied macht und deswegen das
ist ja die schlussfolgerungen daraus aus
dieser erkenntnis die es erst seit
wenigen tagen so belastbar gibt deswegen
nehmen wir dann eine neue bewertung vor
ob es weiterhin ein virus varianten
gebiet bleibt oder nicht vor allem wenn
es dann noch gepaart ist mit dem umstand
dass der anteil in deutschland so
gestiegen sie müssen ja sehen die
brasilianische also ich weiß gar nicht
welchen buchstaben die jetzt hat die
brasilianische und die südafrikanische
variante heute auch mit griechischen
botschaft buchstaben versehen hat es
nicht geschafft in deutschland sich
auszubreiten
mit den klaren regelungen die wir hatten
haben wir es geschafft deren ausbreitung
zu unterbinden
bei der alpha ist es nicht gelungen wie
ist jetzt gerade dominierend bei delta
gelingt es offenkundig auch nicht was
jetzt gelingen muss ist die
infektionszahlen insgesamt niedrig zu
halten
jetzt meine frage im hammer trainer
kommentiert zeitung man frage an herrn
seehofer ich zitiere sie zu
messerangriff von wurden sie haben
gesagt wenn ein junger mann sechs jahre
in einem obdachlosenheim lebt ohne dass
jemand hinschaut und sie konnten sich
kümmert dann kann ich mit unserer
politik nicht zufrieden sein da fällt es
am bewusstsein warum sind sie nicht mit
der politik dieser bundesregierung
zufrieden und wohin sie verlässt
schuldigen kroner bezug oder ja aber das
allgemeine fragen ja aber das müssen sie
mir vorher sagen dann würde ich das als
ende stellen wir bleiben jetzt erst mal
beim heutigen thema und so handhaben wir
das hier gewöhnlich herfried ist der
nächste also ich hab noch in der
nachfrage zu den grenzkontrollen bzw
schleierfahndung sie sagten ja dass in
an der deutsch österreichischen grenze
was ja eine nicht ganz unbedeutende
grenze ist sowieso schon grenzkontrollen
sind aus gründen der terrorprävention
und migrationsfragen sollen die beamten
die dort stehen denn die einreisen denn
dann auch schon stichprobenartig
kontrollieren oder geht da das gleiche
man schaut nur nach den üblichen dingen
und die einreisenden müssen dann damit
rechnen möglicherweise irgendwo im land
kontrolliert zu hören
also der schwerpunkt an der
österreichischen grenze wird weiterhin
die migration und die sicherheitspolitik
sein
natürlich kann bei dieser gelegenheit
die polizei auch die pandemischen
kontrollen dürfen aber ich sage nochmal
nachdem wir nicht von risikogebieten
umgeben sind derzeit jedenfalls das kann
sich ja wie gesagt hoffentlich ändern
wird da das aufkommen an aufgriffen sehr
sehr bescheiden bleiben
uns interessiert hier die der rückkehr
verkehr aus der türkei
das sieht anders aus obwohl die türkei
auch selbst große anstrengungen
unternimmt gerade in ihren
touristenzentren für tests für impfungen
und dergleichen und damit wir dann an
der grenze größeren rückstaus vermeiden
sollte man die verdichtung dagegen über
heute hinter der grenze so wie es ja
schon mal vor einigen monaten der fall
war
durchführen denn ich möchte nicht dass
wir rückstaus bis wien habe ich
übertreibe ich jetzt um vielleicht einen
fall aus der türkei heraus zu fischen
diese verdichtung die hätte ich gern
in dem raum hinter der grenze das hatten
wir schon mal und das hat ohne jede
komplikation funktioniert sie dürfen nie
übersehen dass wir tausendfach
grenzpendler haben dass wir den wahren
und güterverkehr nicht entscheidend
beeinträchtigen möchten die haben uns ja
laufen und wenn also die polizei das
verdichtet in der kontrolle
dann soll sie das so tun dass der übrige
verkehr möglichst wenig behindert wird
hoffe das verständlich natürlich kann
eine ein polizeibeamter der aus
sicherheitsgründen direkt an der grenze
steht heute das mit prüfen woher kommen
sie und sind sie getestet und so weiter
aber die konzentration auf die
pandemische frage die sollte zur
vermeidung größerer probleme in der
ablage im ablauf des verkehrs in der
schleierfahndung erfolgen müssen sie all
die tapferen die sich jetzt zu äußern
man soll stationären grenzkontrollen
einrichten dichter kontrollieren sind
nach meiner erfahrung der letzten
eineinhalb jahre die ersten die wieder
bei uns anrufen und sagen aber da gibt
es doch noch freundinnen und da gibt es
noch die oma und da ist ja hochzeit
vorgesehen last auf die durch und dieses
spiel legen wir nicht ein zweites mal
auf das klingt natürlich so ein bisschen
nach astana fahren also sie lasst uns
alle durch und eben lang soll die
polizei dann in die autos rein gucken
und sagen wer sie türkisch aus dass
manchmal gucken nein nein das ist
relativ einfach es wird ein parkplatz
sowie das letzte mal auch hinter der
grenze dann für die aus leitungen wo man
dann stärker kontrolliert und herkommt
und so weiter benutzt
das hat wunderbar funktioniert damals
also im letzten jahr sogar noch mit dem
test angebot für die menschen da ist aus
geleitet wurden kontrolliert worden und
gleichzeitig ist ein testangebot gemacht
worden
das hat bayern gut organisiert in
abstimmung mit uns wir sind dafür die
grenzkontrollen zuständig und das kann
diesmal auch ähnlich erfolgen ich
übrigens 19 zu finden dafür die debatte
gab es fünf sechs wochen schon mal
teilweise in den üblichen reflexen
befund dass wir letztes jahr während der
sommerzeit aus bestimmten ländern
jedenfalls ein höheres an der höheren
eintrag hatten als aus anderen der ist
ja erstmal ein objektiver ist ein befund
frage es ja was leitet daraus ab
irgendwelche welche folgerungen gibt es
da raus und was ich daraus ableitet
schlicht und ergreifend die bitte sich
testen zu lassen im moment sind auch
etwa die balkan-länder kroatien ist ob
serbien ist kosovo bis auf ganz wenige
regionen gespann schafften nicht
risikogebiet genauso wie ich den
rückreisenden von mallorca bitte kein
risiko
aber bitte für seine eigene sicherheit
und die sicherheit der nächsten sich ein
23 mal zu testen nachdem er sie wieder
in deutschland ist genauso habe ich die
bitte auch an diejenigen die
möglicherweise von einem verwandtschaft
gesucht zurückkehren wenn sie nicht
geimpft sind oder man was natürlich die
dinge noch einfacher macht für alle
beteiligten übrigens auch für die eigene
familie mehr sicherheit gibt auch
diejenigen die man besucht
möglicherweise ist sich impfen zu lassen
weil einfach nur das schauen auf die
zahlen und sehr zeigt wo es jedenfalls
auch ein besonderes risiko letztes jahr
gegeben hat und ich finde sowas kann man
eigentlich auch einfach
wir stellen betrachten auswerten und
daraus zumindest doch mal empfehlungen
dann auch entwickeln ich hab mir noch
eine reihe von fragen die sich auch auf
den reiseverkehr beziehen unter anderem
von christoph schult der spiegel
da geht es um diejenigen die um wege
beschreiten
wie groß ist die befürchtung dass
rückkehrer aus virusvarianten gebieten
nicht direkt nach deutschland zurück
fliegen sondern auf nachbarländer um
rufen und dann auf dem landweg einreisen
und dadurch versuchen sich der
quarantäne pflicht zu entziehen haben
sie diese sorge den eu-nachbarn
mitgeteilt und eine ähnliche frage
stellt matthias roser vom redaktionsbüro
verkehrswege und fragt leisten die
einreise kontrollstellen an den anderen
schengen staatshilfe also meine heimat
meine münsterländische ist ja ich bin
ein in einer stunde ins repol am
flughafen amsterdam der ist für unsere
region bedeutender als die meisten
deutschen flughäfen düsseldorf
vielleicht und deswegen ist jetzt
natürlich ein thema im schengen raum
das gilt ja für viele regionen dass die
nachbarländer und ihre flughäfen ein
thema sind deswegen hätten wir uns
gewünscht da bin ich sehr sicher auch
sehr vorsichtig auch die frau
bundeskanzlerin das war ja auch thema
beim europäischen rat dass es eu
einheitliches vorgehen gibt etwa mit
blick auf virusvarianten gebieten und
dass wir dort
gemeinsames verständnis haben dass bis
man mehr weiß es sinn macht dort strikt
davor zu gehen um den schengen-raum
einen raum der freizügigkeit insgesamt
vor dem eintrag zu schützen es war
leider nicht möglich
bisher bemühen uns weiter jetzt war
bisher leider nicht möglich eine
einheitlichkeit dort zu haben und
gleichwohl sprechen ich jedenfalls in
jedem telefonat in jedem gespräch
der niederländische kollege ist am
montag mit dem königspaar in berlin
bei jedem gespräch das auch entsprechend
an und bitte darum will der mensch
schuld noch sagen was immer der staat
regelt ist gibt erfindungsreiche
menschen die wieder
umgehungsmöglichkeiten kreieren
das ändert aber nichts an der
wirksamkeit der gesamtmaßnahme und
deshalb das was wir jetzt praktizieren
ja nicht einstimmig aber wir wissen auch
wir hatten ja auch im letzten jahr die
stationären grenzkontrollen sogar wir
haben in bayern über 100 grenzübergänge
kontrolliert werden konnten immer nur
die hauptverkehrsadern dass menschen
dann wahnsinnige umwege und umgebungen
auch manchmal in anspruch nehmen
das wissen wir auch aber das lässt sich
dann nur das letzte überhaupt nicht
vermeiden selbst wenn sie sich vornehmen
dass sie alle grenzstationen
kontrollieren im übrigen jedes könntest
du nur darauf hinweisen dass der eintrag
aus dem ausland relativ gering ist nach
der bisherigen erfahrung
jetzt möchte ich noch mal deutlich sagen
deshalb thema spielt sich hier im
luftverkehr ab und weil wir nicht von
risikogebieten umgeben sind ist der
landweg muss auch betrachtet werden aber
es ist nicht das hauptthema jetzt beim
bei der kontrolle da ist wichtiger dass
die gesundheitsämter die qualität wenn
sie denn angezeigt ist überwachen
aber vielleicht kannst du noch mal ich
will da nicht in andere
geschäftsbereiche herumfuhrwerken mal
sagen was uns im kabinett erzählt horst
zu dem eintrag aus dem ausland damit man
das mal wieder richtig einordnet
also stand heute und das ist ja auch im
lagebericht des rk es wöchentlich
aufgearbeitet sind es um die zwei
prozent der infektionen in deutschland
die einen infektionsherd im ausland
zuzuordnen sind und was wir jetzt
natürlich einfach erhalten wollen ist
diese niedrige quote wir haben gesehen
letztes jahr im sommer während der
reisezeit ist dieser anteil auf bis zu
50 prozent gestiegen wochenweise wir
hatten wochenkalender wochen in denen
fast 50 prozent der neuinfektionen in
deutschland einen nachvollziehbaren
ansteckung sword im ausland hatten
und da wollen wir nicht wieder hin
deswegen sind eben die regeln so wichtig
aber deswegen ist vor allem auch wichtig
weil die besten regeln bringen ja nichts
wenn wir das nicht auch gemeinsam als
gesellschaft und jeder für sich auch
mittragen reisen ja urlaub ja genießen
ja aber eben mit vorsicht durch impfen
und testen und quarantäne wo angezeigt
zwei fragen also herr minister sie
erfahren sie zuerst wie wollen sie denn
sie haben gesagt sie wollen die
kontrollen bei den rückkehrern auch an
den flughäfen verschärfen
ich hätte das gerne ein bisschen
konkreter auch gefühlte realität von
vielen rückkehrern die sagen dass sie
eigentlich überhaupt nicht kontrolliert
worden sind und wie beide schieben ja
die verantwortung mit relativer eleganz
den ländern so verspannt an sie die
frage noch immer eine frage machen wir
wieder drauf
letzteres beantwortet sie hat er
entspannt ich könnte ihnen sagen wie es
bei mir war das ist schon wirksam wenn
er stattfindet durch die
gesundheitsämter aber ich glaube jetzt
grenzkontrolle an den flughäfen
die wird heute schon bei drittstaaten
lückenlos durchgeführt da gibt es die
grenzpolizei die kontrolle und jetzt
auch ergänzt die pandemische kontrolle
also die unterlagen wegen der pandemie
zum beispiel russland wäre sein fall als
virusvarianten gebiet und wir haben die
bundespolizei angewiesen
auch innerhalb europas zum beispiel
portugal der diese kontrolle zu
verdichten und das wird auch geschehen
und wird sehr wirksam sein wenn sie
informationen haben das überhaupt keine
kontrolle stattgefunden hätte
sagen sie uns das bitte wir stehen da
gerne für solche informationen zur
verfügung und dann gehen wir demnach das
war ganz am anfang der pandemie habe
haben wir immer wieder solche
informationen bekommen ich weiß immer
noch wie mich die kanzlerin ansprach wie
er sie ansprach dass man ohne jede
probleme das flugzeug verlassen konnte
gebäck abholung und weg und wir haben
das dann immer weiter verdichtet sind
diesen dingen nachgegangen und wir haben
dann nun seit monaten solche
informationen dass es überhaupt nichts
stattfindet nicht mehr bekommen aber das
sagen ist es mir bitte den sie zu
informationen haben was die
gesundheitsämter angeht machen das ja
viele ich finde das jetzt mal weiß zum
beispiel hat mir die frau senatorin noch
berichtet hamburg etwa hat auch sogar
eine eigene einheit zusammengezogen
über alle gesundheitsämter glaubt
hamburger sechs oder sieben glaube ich
gesundheitsämter jedenfalls gesamtstadt
ebene die tatsächlich nichts anderes
machen als stichprobenartig die digitale
einreise anmeldung zu kontrollieren
diejenigen zu kontaktieren
vorbeizufahren anzurufen
die entsprechenden nachweise zu
verlangen und gegebenenfalls eben dann
auch bußgelder zu verhängen
das ist wie mit allen anderen regeln
auch dass wir 100 prozent rollieren
können wir nicht müssen wir auch aus
meiner sicht nicht können erstens mal
halten sich viele bürgerinnen und bürger
auch aus einem gemeinsamen verständnis
dass regeln gelten und dass man
aufeinander aufpasst daran und zweitens
ist es wie bei anderen dingen auch das
stichprobenartige kontrollieren dass die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass wenn man sich
nicht dran hält man frau erwischt wird
muss natürlich da sein und gegeben sein
weil sonst machen regeln ja auch
inspirations bewährte wenig sinn
und ich weiß von vielen
gesundheitsämtern dass sie das machen
ich kann nicht für alle sprechen ich
kann nicht alle überblicken
ich weiß aber dass viele die frei
gewordenen kapazitäten dadurch dass man
sie müssen mal sehen wir haben stand
heute und überlegen um die 12.000 12.000
aktive fälle in deutschland
infektionen das ist eine sehr geringe
zahl wir hatten schon mal fast 400.000
das heißt also der aufwand für
quarantäne und isolations kontrolle bei
infizierten und kontaktpersonen ist
deutlich geringer als noch vor acht zehn
oder zwölf wochen und viele
gesundheitsämter nutzen diese ressourcen
jetzt natürlich auch um die
stichprobenartige kontrolle der
quarantäne bei rückreisenden zu machen
und die digitale ein reiseanmeldung
macht das schon auch eben ein
unterschied wir haben echt manchmal
alles in erinnerung rufen aber wir haben
noch letzten herbst kartons mit papier
aussteige karten durch die republik
gekarrt
wenn es überhaupt aus dem flugzeug
heraus geholt wenn du also außen sind
sie liegen jetzt jedenfalls erfolgtes
digital
ich habe ein erster was ich
entschuldigung für fan fragen sie habe
ich ja seehofer ja ich wollte nur
schnell ergänzt aus meiner eigenen
erfahrung bei der infektion
das erste schreiben dass ich vom
gesundheitsamt in ingolstadt bekommen
habe war die anordnung der isolierung
und dann in fettdruck die androhung
einer geldbuße bis zu 25.000 euro
wenn ich dagegen verstoße
da bleiben sie gerne das zu hause und
frage an sie herr seehofer von jana wolf
von der rheinischen post da geht es um
sie und den außenminister sind es nicht
widersprüchliche signale der
bundesregierung wenn sie zur vorsicht
beim reisen aufrufen und außenminister
maß parallel die pauschale
reisewarnungen aufhebt und wäre eine
generelle test pflicht für alle
reiserückkehrer egal wo ja nicht
sinnvoll gewesen haben wir kein worden
hatte jens spahn gesagt und
außenminister nach einem überblick
richtete er seine reisewarnungen auch
nachdem wie die gebiete eingestuft sind
und das geht nach fachlichen
gesichtspunkten nicht nach politischer
neigung dann würden wir in teufels küche
kommen dann habe ich noch wenn nicht nur
erstens mal können wir nicht einfach mit
also auch ein test pflicht ist ein
eingriff in grundrechte
also ich bin ja immer beeindruckt wie
schnell das alles geht in den
diskussionen in deutschland aber auch
die verpflichtung und vor allem wenn man
es nicht selber macht ist an sich machen
zu lassen
zur testung ist ein eingriff in
grundrechte und ich kann nicht einfach
sagen für jeden egal ob er aus einem
risikogebiet kommt oder nicht
finden wir dass ein die testpflicht für
flugreisen kann man auch herleiten durch
die situation im flug und vielleicht
muss man alles immer gut begründen warum
wir was machen und wir machen dieses
abgestufte konzept das wir haben nicht
zuletzt um die balance zu halten
zwischen freiheitsrechten und
freizügigkeit rechten und sicherheits
und schutz erfordernissen mit blick auf
die pandemie und diese balance gilt es
immer wieder neu auszutarieren und wenn
es da konkrete vorschläge gibt da
bestimmte maßnahmen zu machen sei noch
einmal sind wir beiden glaube ich die
allerletzten die nicht bereit wären
dann auch noch mal was zu ergänzen aber
bei der schalte letzte woche mit dieser
woche montag war es exakt ein bundesland
das einen konkreten vorschlag gemacht
hat und 15 haben den nicht unterstützt
ich mein ich bin ja auch in dem sie
alles zur kenntnis wir die diskussionen
laufen aber 16 gesundheitsminister der
länder haben vor zwei wochen beschlossen
dass das so wie es jetzt ist richtig ist
bei der letzten schalte von bund und
ländern hat ein land gesagt es hätte an
einer stelle eine änderung hat keine
unterstützung bekommen wir als bund
verwehren uns ja gar nicht an einer
solchen diskussion haben wir noch nie
gemacht was die frage der reisewarnungen
angeht kennen wir ja da von einem
ausnahmezustand auch ein stück in einen
normaleren zurück das nicht pauschal
mehr oder weniger die ganze welt
außerhalb der eu mit einer reisewarnung
versehen ist sondern dass reisewarnung
geknüpft sind etwa an die kategorien cds
gebiet und virusvarianten gebiet und das
war eine entscheidung der
bundesregierung die wir glaube ich vor
vier wochen schon getroffen
jetzt habe ich zum zur data variante
noch eine frage von dominique google
muss von ndr
er bezieht sich auf andreas gassen den
chef der kassenärztlichen vereinigung
und referiert erhält die das vergessen
die debatte über die data variante für
hysterisch hält und die intensivbetten
belegung und die todeszahlen in
großbritannien niedrig bleiben hat herr
gassen recht in seiner analyse
naja ich finde manchmal die beiden
hysterisch zu nennen ist schon fast
selbst manchmal wieder mit der gleichen
kategorie
in all dem wünschen dass wir einfach
immer wieder versuchen so schwer das ist
es geht hier um emotionale themen ich
meine ist doch logisch auch jetzt mal
mit blick auf portugal
dass diejenigen die betroffen waren von
einer maßnahme die wir aus
vorsichtsgründen getroffen haben die
gerade in portugal sind oder auf dem weg
nach portugal dass das für ganz viel
frust und verärgerung gesorgt hat zwei
fielen auch für verständnis angesichts
der lage aber viele waren noch einfach
gefrustet
insofern gibt es da immer auch in all
diesen diskussionen natürlich eine
betroffenheit einen sehr
nachvollziehbare und ich kann da nur um
verständnis bitten wir müssen erst mal
wenn wir neue virusvarianten haben wir
nach dem vorsichtsprinzip agieren und
das tun wir generell bei der delta
variante das wäre doch das wäre ich
finde ist fahrlässig wenn eine neue
variante auftaucht bei der es
erkenntnisse gibt vor allem auch dass
sie ansteckender ist bei der es die
entwicklung gibt im vereinigten
königreich die es gibt wenn wir nicht
darauf nach dem vorsichtsprinzip
reagieren würden zumal wir untersucht
viel schmerzen und herten und verlusten
zum teil
das erreicht haben dass wir da sind wo
wir sind nämlich bei niedrigster
instituts das hat ja nicht mal eben so
stattgefunden sondern das ist mit herten
erarbeitet dann finde ich ist es normal
dass wir versuchen das miteinander zu
sichern und das tun wir durch eine
beständige tägliche analyse der lage und
der fakten und ich kann jedenfalls bei
allen die im gesundheitswesen tätig sind
und die ja auch lagen und fakten
erkennen können nur dafür werben dass
wir diese debatte dann auch mit
entsprechenden abwerben führen eher
linke hat noch eine frage ganzen stoffen
gefragt ersparen sie haben ja gestern
im kabinett erklärt dass man die planung
für nächstes jahr aussieht und sie
planen ohne chor weg aber andererseits
mit fast einem drittel der impfdosen der
204 millionen
die auch von herstellern kommen die noch
keine zulassung haben droht da nicht
mehr gefahr dass sie da mit ausfällen
rechnen müssen wie wollen sie damit
umgehen
also wir haben als bundesregierung und
auch ich vorletzte woche im ministerrat
in luxemburg immer dafür geworben dass
wir auf europäischer ebene und ansonsten
hätten wir sie national ergänzt eine
zwei plus zwei strategie fahren für 2022
23 was mein 222 m rna hersteller und
zwei weitere technologie und bei den
herstellern ist es nun mal objektiv so
dass es zwei gibt die einen zugelassenen
impfstoff haben die in der entwicklung
von varianten angepassten impfstoffen
von studien zur auffrischimpfung und von
kinder impfstoffen relativ weit sind sie
bei entdeckung moderner die auch beide
sich in den verträgen die jetzt
geschlossen sind was übrigens die frage
von lieferverpflichtungen angeht
vertragsstrafen bei nichtlieferung
produktionsstätten in der eu sich zu
deutlich mehr verpflichtet haben als in
den bisherigen verträgen deswegen finde
ich es naheliegend diese verträge nun
zuerst einmal mit denjenigen zu
schließen tatsächlich auch ein produkt
am markt haben recht es so formulieren
darf und die anderen die sie
angesprochen haben beziehen sich ja auf
die zwei weiteren technologien vor allem
die protein basierten impfstoff sanofi
und nowaks die beide mittlerweile sanofi
auch nach einem rückschlag relativ weit
sind und wir haben sogar einen kleinen
anteil eines vektorbasierte impfstoffes
weiterhin vorgesehen für alle fälle
nämlich 18 millionen dosen von johnson &
johnson so dass wir tatsächlich die
strategie die wir dieses jahr gefahren
haben oder letztes jahr auf mehrere
pferde setzen ja der biontech vertrag
alleine würde wahrscheinlich schon
reichen wenn er denn sicher kommt
und wissen sie vor eineinhalb jahren
hätte ein jeder gesagt setzt auf astra
zyniker und fuhr weg
hätten wir vor eineinhalb jahren nur
verträge geschlossen mit astra zenica
und fuhr weg
dann hätten wir ein echtes problem und
deswegen ist die eine herangehensweise
die wo spare ich in der konkreten
einzelentscheidung möglicherweise was
ein und die andere frage ist wie gebe
ich und sicherheit dass wir vielleicht
bei impfstoffen etwas mehr bezahlen
dafür aber ziemlich viel kostspieliger
andere dinge wie etwa beschränkungen der
wirtschaft und des täglichen lebens
vermeiden können und deswegen fahren wir
diese strategie auch fürs nächste jahr
zwei hersteller zwei weitere
technologien und deutlich mehr unter
vertrag nehmen als wir brauchen
ich sage das nur deswegen weil ich sehr
sicher bin ein paar monaten wird das vom
bundesrechnungshof kritisiert werden
dieser ansatz das ist aber eine bewusste
politische entscheidung
der in umfragen ist die frage zielte
bisschen darauf dass sanofi vor zum
beispiel er noch gar keine zulassung hat
sie fürchten also nicht dass da eine
lücke entstehen kann weil sie auch auf
dem stoff ersetzen die noch nicht
zugelassen wird
dadurch dass wir jetzt wieder einen
breiten mix machen mit zwei impfstoffen
wie gesagt m rna mit dem wir schon gute
erfahrungen haben und zwei neuen
technologien sind wir sehr
zuversichtlich dass wir ausreichend mehr
als ausreichend aber auch mit dem
nötigen sicherheitspuffer für
deutschland und die eu geht ja nicht nur
um uns auch fürs nächste und übernächste
jahr haben werden also die regner von
dpa befragte zu diesen 204 millionen
impfdosen für das kommende jahr wie sind
die begründet und sind die im eu-rahmen
abgesprochen
die begründung die herleitung ist genau
der sicherheitspuffer den ich gerade
angesprochen habe wenn sie die deutschen
zweimal impfen wollen alle jeden
theoretisch bei uns 166 millionen
impfdosen mit zusätzlichen
sicherheitspuffer haben wir dann im 204
hergeleitet mit verschiedenen
herstellern abgesichert was ich weiß
jetzt nicht genau was mit abgesprochen
gemeint ist der biontech und der moderne
anteil
in diesem in dieser herangehensweise
sind bereits vertraglich gesichert auf
europäischer ebene für deutschland
sanofi bis der vertrag ja noch wieder in
geltung gebracht ja schon bestanden hat
auf europäischer ebene und auch bei nova
wachs und bei newa haben wir unsere
mengen wünsche angemeldet die wahrheit
ist übrigens ein solches noch anführen
darf viele dieser verträge kämen ohne
dass deutschland sich so klar komme
nicht zustande
es gibt durchaus länder die nicht eine
so auf puffer fahrende strategie fahren
wie wir und wenn sich die bundesrepublik
deutschland nicht mit ihrer auch größe
und wirtschaftskraft an diesen verträgen
so beteiligen würde wie wir es tun hätte
die ganze eu weniger sicherheit das ist
neben dem eigenen blickwinkel auch ein
europäischer dem wieder einnehmen
dann gibt es einmal die bitte ob sie in
zahlen ausgedrückt ausdrücken können
warum die prognose ein impfangebot für
alle im juni hergibt
für jeden erwachsenen
ich frag gleich zu den kindern gibt ich
habe gerade gesagt zwei von drei
erwachsenen in deutschland sind
mindestens einmal geimpft werden jetzt
gut 45 millionen hilft wir haben etwa 70
knapp 70 millionen erwachsene in
deutschland eine bereitschaft von 100
prozent ist leider nicht zu erwarten
ich würde mir sehr wünschen aber sie ist
nicht zu erwarten und wenn sie dann mit
impfbereitschaft die wir in umfragen
sehen von 75 80 prozent arbeiteten dann
sehen sie dass mit den lieferungen
allein an ma impfstoffen die wir für den
juli erwarten diese erstimpfung möglich
sind wir haben zusätzlich die die
führung von astra chemiker und johnson &
johnson insofern unter der voraussetzung
natürlich aber gerade bei moderner und
beyond ich haben wir mittlerweile eine
hohe verlässlichkeit dass diese
lieferung kommen werden wir dieses
angebot machen können was sie übrigens
sehen und das bewegt mich im moment
eigentlich noch mehr ist dass wir jetzt
in die phase kommen ich meine das ist ja
wollte mich
und der vor vier wochen mancher welcher
in den ländern gesagt habe im juli wird
sich das sehr verändern als alle gesagt
haben wir brauchen mehr impfstoff
hier werden ja bald das system umstellen
können und müssen
neudeutsch würde man sagen on demand
wir werden den ländern dann nur noch
liefern was sie bestellen aber dass dann
auch vollständig warum weil die ersten
die länder uns ja schon sagen wenn wir
das nicht mehr alles verhilft legen
lagern möchten wir das aber nicht bei
uns bei minus 70 grad hunderttausende
von dosen können wir das nicht so machen
dass ihr das erst mal bei euch behaltet
das ist jetzt noch nicht so aber es wird
absehbar bald eine phase kommen und die
bereiten wir vor wo alles das was
bestellt wird von impfzentren arztpraxen
und betriebsärzten wir auch werden
bedienen und ausliefern können und den
rest werden wir lagern um
auffrischimpfungen oder unsere
unterstützung bei kovacs daneben auch
leisten zu können
jetzt kommen noch die versprochene frage
zu den kindern und jugendlichen von
rasmus buchsteiner von pioneer müssten
nicht angesichts der ausbreitung der
delta variante die impfung bei den
zwölf- bis 15-jährigen ausgeweitet
werden und inwiefern ist die empfehlung
der stiko die hier die delta variante
noch nicht berücksichtigt hat ein
hemmnis
also ich treffe am montag habe ich
gerade schon gesagt man niederländischen
kollegen der junge und ich werde ihn
noch fragen die niederlande haben
gestern entschieden dies die zwölf- bis
15-jährigen sozusagen mit empfehlungen
zu impfen
auf welcher basis zum beispiel die
niederländer zu dieser entscheidung
gekommen sind
am ende kennt ihn kennen viele ja die
aktuelle lage es gibt eine empfehlung
der ständigen impfkommission die keine
generelle empfehlung bedeutet für zwölf-
bis 18-jährige wie gleichzeitig aber
eben sagt nach individueller
entscheidung des zu impfenden
gegebenenfalls mit dem sorgeberechtigten
und dem impfen arzt ist eine solche
impfung möglich ich kann halten
tatsächlich hier nur eines machen und
das machen wir auch und zwar sehr
bewusst wenn jemand sich entscheidet
zwischen 12 und 18 jahren für sich ist
übrigens eine frage der
einsichtsfähigkeit wenn der arzt fest
stellt der oder diejenige kann
alleine entscheiden auch mit 15 oder 17
jahren kann er kämpft kann der arzt die
impfung vornehmen
nach eigener einschätzung oder eben mit
dem sorgeberechtigten wenn die
entscheidung da ist möchte ich nur eins
sicher stellen dass der impfstoff da ist
und das können wir sicher stellen wir
können für jeden zwölf- bis 18-jährigen
in deutschland der geimpft werden will
sicherstellen dass auch er oder sie
spätestens bis ende august eine erste
impfung erhalten haben wird und die
zweitimpfung in vorgesehener intervall
folgt und alles andere ist die
individuelle entscheidung unter
berücksichtigung verschiedener
empfehlungen der kinder jugendlichen und
ihrer eltern
jetzt ist noch eine nachfolge von anne
beatrice clasmann von dpa zu den
sogenannten überschüssigen impfstoff
bekommen die gelagert werden sie fragt
ist auch vorgesehen anteil abzugeben in
entwicklungsländer
die frau bundeskanzlerin hat ja schon
für die bundesregierung erklärt dass wir
30 millionen mindestens 30 millionen
impfdosen in diesem jahr beitragen
werden neben das muss man übrigens mal
dazu sagen neben dem finanziellen
engagement
deutschland ist der zweitgrößte
geldgeber bei kovacs neben dem
finanziellen engagement geben wir auch
haben wir auch erklärt die bereitschaft
impfdosen als solche zusätzlich
abzugeben
von den 100 millionen dosen die die
europäische union jetzt in einem ersten
schritt zur verfügung stellt stellen
frankreich und deutschland jeweils 30
millionen also einen überproportionalen
anteil zur verfügung im zweiten halbjahr
und das werden wir auch machen ob
darüber hinaus hier zur verfügung
stellen können
schon in diesem jahr das würde ich gerne
entscheiden wenn wir für uns das thema
auffrischimpfungen entschieden haben ich
rechne bald mit empfehlungen der
ständigen impfkommission was
immunsupprimierten menschen angeht und
den notwendigkeit eine auffrischimpfung
wir bereiten gedanklich natürlich vor
mit den ländern in gesprächen mögliche
auffrischimpfungen den
pflegeeinrichtungen pflegebedürftige
menschen rechtzeitig vor herbst und
winter und auch für darüber hinaus
gehende mögliche auffrischimpfungen
werden wir natürlich den impfstoff jetzt
so aus den lieferungen zur seite legen
das ist jedenfalls dann losgehen kann
ohne mangel sondern die
auffrischimpfungen tatsächlich dann auch
zügig in kurzer zeit erfolgen können
dann habe ich noch eine hier aus diesem
bereich eine letzte frage nachfrage von
den gogos zum thema quarantäne
sie haben angedeutet ersparen dass
aufgrund von neuen erkenntnissen über
die wirkung der vollständigen impfung
geimpfte die aus varianten gebieten
einreisen nicht mehr in quarantäne
müssen in welchem zeitraum wird die
quarantäne pflicht für geimpfte fallen
es ist mir zu pauschal ich habe gesagt
wir wissen bezogen auf die delta
variante dass der impfstoff bei
zweifacher impfung oder folgen
impfschutz wirkt es kann ja eine
variante geben was gott verhüten möge wo
der impfstoff nicht mehr wirkt und wo
wir eine völlig andere situation hätten
deswegen kann ich jetzt nicht generell
sagen bei virusvarianten gebieten gilt
das aber mit blick auf delta habe ich ja
gerade das weitere verfahren beschrieben
ich weiß ich sage noch einmal wir wissen
auch aus den rückmeldungen im
ministerium und online und sozialen
medien aus persönlicher empirie im
bekanntenkreis dass die frage geimpft
aus portugal zurück reisen quarantäne
natürlich eine 14 tage quarantäne ist
nicht nichts ist die gerade auch mit
nachvollziehbarer emotionen diskutiert
wird vor allem mit blick darauf dass zur
delta aus den letzten tagen die
erkenntnisse vorliegen und deswegen
werden wir da zügig zu entsprechenden
schlussfolgerungen kommen aber ich lege
schon wert darauf es gilt das
vorsichtsprinzip wir wollen erstmal was
wissen über diese varianten bevor wir
sie anders behandeln sie jetzt keine
corona fragen mehr hier im saal und auch
von außen nicht dann haben sie das wort
zu einem anderen thema man von herrn
seehofer warum sind die mit der
integrationspolitik der bundesregierung
nicht zufrieden wir sind sie müssen noch
so einen brutalen schrecklichen
verbrechen wie in würzburg
neben der aufklärung immer auch
überlegen was können wir tun
um das für die zukunft vielleicht zu
vermeiden oder jedenfalls
unwahrscheinlicher zu machen die sache
mit der islamistischen gesinnung und der
psychologischen erkrankung die muss
weiter aufgeklärt werden kann ich jetzt
nichts neues mitteilen und auch nicht
abschließend bewerten
bei der betrachtung der biografie des
täters komme ich zu dem ergebnis wenn
jemand sechs jahre lang rechtmäßig in
deutschland ist und mit 24 jahren im
obdachlosenheim und erkennbar keine
maßnahme erhöhung zum erfolg geführt hat
dass dann in diesem falle einfach sicher
stattgefundene bemühungen gescheitert
sind und damit auch in einem fall unsere
politik auch ich bin für integration
zuständig neben vielen anderen
das muss man offen benennen und muss mit
den ländern und kommunen ähnlich hat
sich ja übrigens der oberbürgermeister
von wörz geäußert schauen was können wir
noch tun um solche menschen besser zu
betreuen
gerade wenn sie auch krank sind und oder
offenbar gang sind so muss ich zum
jetzigen zeitpunkt formulieren und dann
müssen wir die integrationsmaßnahmen
verbessern ich habe ein erstes gespräch
dazu in meinem hause geführt bevor wir
mit ländern und kommunen reden zum
beispiel muss man viel stärker
unterscheiden zwischen den
herkunftsländern die ja ganz andere
kulturen haben mit somalia ist es sicher
etwas anderes als mit tunesien
wir müssen stärker auf die altersgruppen
achten
zwischen 15 und 30 lebensjahren ist die
integration vielleicht etwas anderes als
mit 50 lebensjahren und sofort und so
weiter es wäre aus meiner sicht ja
schlimm wenn die politik nach einem
brutalen verbrechen den mantel des
schweigens darüber breitet und nicht
sich nicht gedanken macht was können wir
verbessern und müssen wir verbessern und
wir müssen in der integrationsarbeit
viel verbessern
ich sage ausgesprochen viel wir
analysieren ja zum beispiel solche dinge
wie in stuttgart wo dann
randale stattfindet und fensterscheiben
eingeschlagen werden wer hat sich da
beteiligt und gibt es nicht zu viele
zuwanderer in jüngeren jahren die
entwurzelt sind die orientierungslos
sind und die eine verstärken wenn sie
ein anspruch auf aufenthalt in der
bundesrepublik deutschland haben
dass wir sie besser dass wir uns besser
um sie kümmern und das halte ich für die
pflicht initiierten politikers wie man
was meinen sie mit sie besser schützen
ich habe ihre antwort am ende nicht
verstanden was sollen sie machen einen
kongress der der kampf gegen
radikalisierung extremismus und
ähnliches hat er immer das eigene
medaille mit zwei seiten das eine ist
der starke staat die repression
wir haben sehr viele polizeibeamte
eingestellt werden die
sicherheitsbehörden gestärkt wir haben
die befugnisse erweitert all dies gehört
zum teil der repression aber der andere
teil ist genauso wichtig nämlich der
teil der prävention und der integration
und wenn sie prävention und integration
intensiv gestalten können sie auch
extremistischen bewegen
entwicklungen und auch einfach die
integration in die gesellschaft
verstärken und damit solche schlimmen
dinge zurück trägern ich sage
ausdrücklich sie kein politiker kann
versprechen sie völlig zu vermeiden
aber wir sollten unsere anstrengungen
noch mal erhöhen
so will ich mich klar verstanden wissen
ich bin sehr froh ich habe mich mit ihm
nicht abgesprochen dass ein
kommunalpolitiker nämlich der
oberbürgermeister der stadt würzburg
ähnlichen ergebnis kommt indessen
stadtgesellschaft lebte der junge mann
ja und deshalb müssen wir den dingen
nachgehen und wir werden das auch tun
trotz wahlkampf und so weiter das ist
bitter notwendig wir haben noch zu viele
gerade jüngere menschen die in der
bundesrepublik deutschland die
zugewandert sind die ein
aufenthaltsrecht haben und die aus
meiner sicht noch nicht hinreichend
integriert sind
es ist schwer muss mir niemand erzählen
in der sprache in der vorbildung den
menschen kommen die nicht von rechts von
links nach rechts schreiben sondern von
rechts nach links das ist alles nicht so
einfach wie man das oberflächlich auf
diskutiert aber wir müssen uns dieser
thematik stärker stellen möchte jetzt
mit blick auf die uhr und die
fortgeschrittene zeit fragen ob es jetzt
noch fragen gibt hessen habe ich gesehen
und dann hat er für heute die letzte
frage und wenn ich die pressekonferenz
herr seehofer soweit man weiß war einer
der ersten der sich unter hohem eigenen
risiko dem attentäter entgegengestellt
hat ein asylbewerber muslimischen
glaubens man kann diese beiden personen
und sachen nicht gegeneinander
aufrechnen
das ist klar aber es ist eine bandbreite
die beides mit menschen die einer
bestimmten religion einem bestimmten
sozialen status hier
zugehörig sind miteinander verbindet
welche lehren oder was können sie als
konsequenz aus dieser bandbreite ziehen
ja sie gehören ja zu denen die fast
jedes mal hier sind in der
bundespressekonferenz deshalb darf ich
sie nur erinnern dass wir bei jeder
gelegenheit ob mit dem bundeskriminalamt
oder zuletzt mit dem bundesamt für
verfassungsschutz auf die insgesamt hohe
bedrohungslage mit extremisten aus allen
richtungen hinweisen
ich bin dann immer überrascht dass es
kaum aufgegriffen wird ich will es
deshalb heute wiederholen
rechtsextremismus sehr sehr stark
islamismus leider immer wieder mit
grässlichen brutalen verbrechen
linksextremismus der immer gewalt
affiner wert und die sogenannten reichs
bürger und ich weiß sie bei der
gelegenheit immer darauf hin dass man in
den einzelnen gruppen nicht
verallgemeinern darf und was ich für
ganz bedenklich halten würde wenn man
die eine entwicklung mit einer anderen
relativiert was ich ja oft zu hören
bekomme was regst du dich das über über
diese strömung was man sich jetzt
rechtsextremismus auf es gibt doch auch
ein linksextremismus sagte sie man hier
in der bundespressekonferenz
das wissen wir und wir rechnen dass
einige beim anderen auf oder
rechtfertigen nicht die eine entwicklung
mit der anderen beim islam kommt noch in
einer bildbetrachtung dazu dass hier die
strömungen einstellungen auch sehr
vielfältig sind innerhalb des islam
es ist für mich als innenminister oft
sehr schwierig jemanden als
gesprächspartner zu haben der für sich
in anspruch nehmen kann ich vertrete die
moslems im lande
wir sehen die breite und die macht
gerade bei der integration auch
schwierig wir haben den die islam
konferenz
es gibt auch in meiner fraktion
auch strömungen denen bin ich gefolgt
die sagen wir haben auch einen
politischen islamismus
das sind leute die glauben benutzen um
eine system überwindung anzustrengen und
da habe ich jetzt auch erst einen
sachverständigenrat gebildet der sich
mit dieser problematik beschäftigt und
mich in bayern noch zuständig reich
konnte zum neujahrsempfang die moslems
bayerns nicht einladen weil sie keinen
vertreter hatten auf denen sie sich
verständigen konnten
das ist leider so und deshalb ist müssen
wir viel fällt text ansätzen in der
ganzen breite die sie jetzt angedeutet
haben und da dürfen sie sich darauf
verlassen
da ist die bundesregierung in diesen
letzten jahren ganz ganz intensiv dabei
und ich würde sie auch noch mal bitten
den linksextremismus zu rechtfertigen
weil es um rechtsextremismus gibt und
weil es diese beiden gibt haben wir auch
noch rechtfertigung für den islamismus
das ist alles eine hohe bedrohung aus
jeder richtung
ich kann nur immer wieder darauf
hinweisen und wenn wir von einer hohen
bedrohung sprechen heißt es übersetzt
aus welcher richtung auch immer wir
müssen jederzeit mit einem anschlag
rechnen mit diesen worten beendete diese
pressekonferenz ich danke allen die
gekommen sind besonders den beiden
ministern herrn seehofer und herrn spahn
und wünsche uns allen
erfolgreicher tag